what can you do it the easier if I show
you shoot white glide when you can fly
sunglasses indoors what can you do
I am Phantom Rider I can pee and or poop
my pants at the same time that's not a
power and then do it right now
I'm not gonna poop or pee my pants right
now that's because you can't I can't if
I wanted to then do it no ask me to do
it no that's gross anybody else any
takers I think we're good actually
I think it's best if you just leave is
is this how everyone else feels well I
know when I'm not wanted
[Music]
I do how do you follow I just saw weird
everything else is in place earth will
be destroyed unless someone poops or
pees their pants right now think I miss
this party
now
they made me you know where to find me
actually we don't
oh I'm by the Del Taco on Havenhurst
it's pretty cool rents cheap
you